This is 99% Invisible. I'm Christopher Johnson. It's February 2nd, 2014, and you're balancing a plate of wings and blue cheese dip on your lap, watching the Seattle Seahawks thrash the Denver Broncos into Super Bowl. Then, during one of the commercial breaks, you see this ad. In the middle of the screen, it says, Congo Brazzaville. There's a group of men doing hard, dirty says, Congo Brazzaville. There's a group of men doing hard, dirty work, clearing fields and fixing cars. In life, you cannot always choose what you do.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是克里斯托弗·约翰逊。今天是2014年2月2日，你正坐在膝盖上平衡着一盘鸡翅和蓝纹奶酪蘸酱，看着西雅图海鹰队在超级碗比赛中痛击丹佛野马队。然后，在其中一个广告时段，你看到了这个广告。屏幕中央写着“刚果布拉柴维尔”。有一群人正在做着艰苦、肮脏的工作，清理田地和修理汽车。在生活中，你不能总是选择你做什么。
But you can always choose who you are. Next thing you know, the ad cuts to a new scene. It's the evening, and now we're at a bar. This is producer Ryan Lenora Brown. A crowd has formed a circle around those same men, who have shed their dirty work clothes for coral pink, canary, and bright tangerine-colored suits. One by one, the men proudly strut and pose, twirling their gold pocket watches, snapping their suspenders, and shooting their cuffs as the crowd cheers them on.
但你总能选择你想成为什么样的人。接下来，广告切换到了一个新的场景。那是傍晚，我们现在在一家酒吧里。这是制作人瑞安·莱诺拉·布朗。人群围成了圆圈，中间是刚才那群人，他们已经脱下了肮脏的工作服，换上了珊瑚粉、金丝雀黄和亮橘色的西装。他们一个接一个地骄傲地昂首阔步、摆出姿势，转动着金色的怀表，弹动着背带，整理着袖口，人群为他们欢呼。
In the corner, a bartender smiles approvingly as he pours a glass of Guinness. You see my friends, with every brace and every cufflinks, we say, I am the master of my fate. I am the captain of my soul. Okay so I admit, at first glance it may seem a bit out of left field that a group of Congolese men dressed like an exquisitely elegant pack of highlighters is out here selling Irish beer during the Super Bowl. But actually, everyone from cinematographers to musicians to style mavens have finally been catching on to this loose-knit collective of dandies called Sappors.
在角落里，一位酒保微笑着点头，倒了一杯吉尼斯啤酒。你看，我的朋友们，每一次挺胸抬头，每一对袖扣，我们都在说：我是我命运的主宰，我是我灵魂的船长。好吧，我承认，乍一看，一群穿着像精致优雅的荧光笔套装一样的刚果男人在超级碗期间卖爱尔兰啤酒，似乎有点离谱。但实际上，从电影摄影师到音乐家，再到时尚达人，每个人终于开始关注这个被称为“萨普尔”（Sappeurs）的松散绅士团体了。
They're from the central African cities of Brazzaville and Kinshasa, and since the 1970s, they've been known for donning technicolor three-piece suits with flamboyant accessories like golden walking sticks and leopard print fedoras, and then catwalking through their city streets. In recent years, the Sappores have blown up. Solange, Kendrick, and SZA have all featured Sappores in their music videos.
他们来自中非城市布拉柴维尔和金沙萨，自20世纪70年代以来，他们就以穿着色彩鲜艳的三件套西装，搭配金手杖和豹纹软呢帽等浮夸配饰，并在城市街道上走猫步而闻名。近年来，“萨普尔”风靡一时。索兰格、肯德里克和SZA都在他们的音乐录影带中邀请了“萨普尔”成员。
The iconic British menswear designer Paul Smith did a whole spring line of Sappore-inspired suits and bowler hats. If you want to be delighted, do a real quick image search. When you see the Sappores, it's obvious what makes them so attractive to famous artists and global brands. Their remix on classic menswear is irreverent and colorful and just a joy to look at. And these images are really different from the stereotypical way that sub-Saharan Africa is often portrayed to the world. Those images depict the region as broke and broken. As an American journalist who's worked here for the past decade, I've seen those stereotypes. We all have. And the reality is, life in places like the Congo is really difficult, especially
标志性的英国男装设计师保罗·史密斯推出了整个春季系列的“萨普尔”风格西装和圆顶礼帽。如果你想获得惊喜，可以快速进行图片搜索。当你看到“萨普尔”时，很明显是什么让他们对著名艺术家和全球品牌如此具有吸引力。他们对经典男装的重新演绎既不敬又多彩，看起来简直是一种享受。这些形象与撒哈拉以南非洲通常向世界展示的刻板印象截然不同。那些形象将该地区描绘成贫穷和破碎的。作为一名过去十年在这里工作的美国记者，我见过这些刻板印象。我们都见过。现实是，像刚果这样的地方，生活确实很艰难，尤其是
after centuries of brutal colonization, resource extraction, and underdevelopment. Into that bleak frame strolls the Sappors, these Congolese mechanics and construction workers and farmhands dressed up like aristocratic peacocks, flaunting their Ferragamo monk strap shoes, silk Chanel scarves, and crisp Versace suits. For Sappors, looking that clean is like two huge f**k yous. One for the cards they've been dealt and the other to anyone who thinks those circumstances could ever define them. At the root of this is this phenomena of having agency and using style. Chantrell Lewis is author of the book, Dandelion, the Black Dandy and Street Style,
在经历了几个世纪的残酷殖民、资源掠夺和欠发达之后。在这阴郁的背景下，走来了“萨普尔”，这些刚果机械师、建筑工人和农场工人打扮得像贵族孔雀，炫耀着他们的菲拉格慕僧侣鞋、香奈儿丝巾和挺括的范思哲西装。对于“萨普尔”来说，穿得如此整洁就像是两个巨大的“去你的”。一个是对他们所遭遇的命运，另一个是对任何认为这些环境可以定义他们的人。这一切的根源在于拥有自主权并运用风格的现象。尚特雷尔·刘易斯是《蒲公英：黑人绅士与街头风格》一书的作者，
which features the Sappores. Black men have taken the European suit and fashioned it with traditional African sensibilities. I'm talking about color, I'm talking about swag, I'm talking about using the European suit to defy their material conditions, defy their realities. For more than a century, Black dandies like the Sappores have been engaged in what Chantrell
书中介绍了“萨普尔”。黑人男性采用了欧洲西装，并用传统的非洲审美对其进行了改造。我说的是色彩，我说的是风度，我说的是利用欧洲西装来反抗他们的物质条件，反抗他们的现实。一个多世纪以来，像“萨普尔”这样的黑人绅士一直从事着尚特雷尔
calls dapper agitation. It's a counterintuitive kind of rebellion, right? Because in a way, formal wear is all about conformity. That's why we call people suits. And jackets and ties came to this part of the world in a particularly ugly and violent way. They were brought by colonizers who made dressing European a precondition for being treated like a human being.
所说的“绅士式煽动”。这是一种反直觉的叛逆，对吧？因为在某种程度上，正装就是关于从众。这就是为什么我们称人为“西装”。夹克和领带以一种特别丑陋和暴力的方式来到了这个地区。它们是由殖民者带来的，他们将穿着欧洲服装作为被当作人对待的前提条件。
But the Sappors have flipped that script in dramatic fashion. They've taken the European suit, this thing that was forced on them, and made it wholly, authentically Congolese. And they've done it so well that now it's the rest of us trying to wear our clothes to look like them. This radical fashion transformation began way before anybody in the Congo was calling themselves a Sappor. In fact, it started before the Congo was even a country of its own. It goes back to the first generations of Congolese men to put on suits and ties. In fact, it started before the Congo was even a country of its own. It goes back to the first generations of Congolese men to put on suits and ties. Men like Frederick Mpenda.
但“萨普尔”以戏剧性的方式扭转了这一局面。他们拿走了欧洲西装，这个强加给他们的东西，并使它变得完全、地道地属于刚果。他们做得如此出色，以至于现在是我们其他人试图穿上衣服来模仿他们。这种激进的时尚转型早在刚果没有人自称“萨普尔”之前就开始了。事实上，它在刚果成为一个独立的国家之前就开始了。它追溯到第一代穿西装打领带的刚果男性。事实上，它在刚果成为一个独立的国家之前就开始了。它追溯到第一代穿西装打领带的刚果男性。像弗雷德里克·姆彭达这样的男人。
OK, I just have to be a little bit ready. Are you OK? Yeah, mom, but… It's a sticky September day in Kinshasa, the capital of the Democratic Republic of the Congo. I'm sitting under a leafy mango tree in Frederick's yard. He's 89, dressed in the international off-duty grandpa uniform, a gray polo shirt and blue track pants. But 70 years ago, his fashion sense was a little different.
好吧，我只需要准备一下。你还好吗？是的，妈妈，但是……这是金沙萨一个粘稠的九月天，金沙萨是刚果民主共和国的首都。我坐在弗雷德里克院子里的一棵多叶芒果树下。他89岁，穿着国际通用的退休爷爷制服：灰色Polo衫和蓝色运动裤。但70年前，他的时尚感有点不同。
Frederick flips open a photo album and points to a black and white picture. There's a young man wearing a chic gray suit and tasseled loafers, holding a chunky baby with rolls like the Michelin Man. That's me, that's me, he says, pointing to the man in the suit. He turns to another photo of himself. This one is from the 1950s. Frederick is sitting on his bicycle, wearing a crisp white button down
弗雷德里克翻开相册，指着一张黑白照片。照片里有一个年轻人穿着别致的灰色西装和流苏乐福鞋，抱着一个像米其林轮胎人一样胖乎乎的婴儿。“那是我，那是我，”他指着那个穿西装的男人说。他翻到另一张自己的照片。这张是20世纪50年代的。弗雷德里克骑在自行车上，穿着一件挺括的白色衬衫，
and throwing the camera a brooding, serious gaze. His hair is close-cropped, and there's a long, straight part running through it. Look at that part! We were always trying to imitate white people, even though our hair is nappy. Frederick talks casually about it now, but when this photo was taken, imitating how white people dressed was a matter of survival here. Back then, the Democratic Republic of the Congo, or the DRC, was a colony of the Belgians. They believed they needed to, quote, civilize the primitive Congolese,
向镜头投去忧郁、严肃的目光。他的头发剪得很短，中间有一条笔直的缝。看那条缝！我们总是试图模仿白人，尽管我们的头发是卷曲的。弗雷德里克现在谈起这件事很随意，但当这张照片拍摄时，模仿白人的穿着在这里是生存问题。那时，刚果民主共和国，或称刚果（金），是比利时的殖民地。他们认为他们需要“教化”原始的刚果人，
making them less African and more white. Growing up in the 1940s, Frederick's white school teachers made it crystal clear that the only way a Congolese boy like him could get ahead in life was to aspire to be as European as he possibly could. Frederick took their advice to heart.
让他们少一点非洲味，多一点白人味。在20世纪40年代长大，弗雷德里克的白人老师们非常清楚地表明，像他这样的刚果男孩想要在生活中出人头地的唯一途径，就是尽可能地向欧洲人靠拢。弗雷德里克把他们的建议记在了心里。
As a young man, he perfected his French, he got his diploma, and in the 1950s he took a job with the colonial government in Leopoldville, what's now Kinshasa. But of course, the Belgians were wild racists who by this point had already spent more than a half century plundering Congo's minerals using slave labor. They didn't actually believe that someone like Frederick would ever be equal to them. So Frederick found himself continually having to prove how Belgian he could be, like when he applied to be an assistant to a colonial administrator.
作为一个年轻人，他完善了自己的法语，拿到了文凭，并在20世纪50年代在利奥波德维尔（现在的金沙萨）的殖民政府找到了一份工作。但当然，比利时人是疯狂的种族主义者，到那时为止，他们已经花了半个多世纪的时间利用奴隶劳动掠夺刚果的矿产。他们并不真正相信像弗雷德里克这样的人会与他们平等。因此，弗雷德里克发现自己必须不断证明自己能有多“比利时化”，比如当他申请担任殖民行政官的助理时。
You first did a short exam. If you passed the exam, you went to the hospital so they could see if you were physically fit or not. If they decided you were fit, they handed you a little bottle of cologne. In a thousand ways, the Belgians tried to erase the Africaness of the Congolese. In order to succeed, you had to speak and act and even smell like a white person. This was especially true for Frederick. That's because he was considered an évolué, which literally means an evolved one. That's what the Belgians called a Congolese person who
你首先要参加一个简短的考试。如果你通过了考试，你就去医院，让他们看看你的身体是否健康。如果他们认为你健康，他们就会给你一小瓶古龙水。比利时人通过一千种方式试图抹去刚果人的非洲特征。为了成功，你必须像白人一样说话、行动，甚至闻起来像白人。这对弗雷德里克来说尤其如此。这是因为他被认为是“进化者”（évolué），字面意思是“进化过的人”。这就是比利时人对刚果人的称呼，他们
broke ties with their African identity and their community, and instead adopted a European system of values. Evolué status gave people like Frederick access to education, jobs, and neighborhoods that most Congolese would never receive. But it also meant constantly being subjected to humiliating rituals. You will find the white agent at the door. When you arrive at work, you will find a white man at the door.
切断了与非洲身份和社区的联系，转而采用了欧洲的价值观体系。这种“进化者”身份让像弗雷德里克这样的人获得了大多数刚果人永远无法获得的教育、工作和居住区。但也意味着必须不断忍受羞辱性的仪式。你会发现门口有白人代理人。当你到达工作地点时，你会发现门口有一个白人。
He would smell you. And if you did not smell good, if you did not wear the cologne, he will send you home. In our time, it was like that. You could not be unclean. Evo Luais were expected to speak crisp French, eat with a knife and fork, and go to mass on Sundays. Sitting with Frederick in his yard in Kinshasa, he explains to me that being an Evoluée meant having to look European, too.
他会闻你。如果你闻起来不好，如果你没有喷古龙水，他会让你回家。在我们那个时代，就是这样。你不能不干净。“进化者”被要求说流利的法语，用刀叉吃饭，周日去教堂做弥撒。在金沙萨的院子里和弗雷德里克坐在一起，他向我解释说，成为“进化者”也意味着必须看起来像欧洲人。
It's at this point in our conversation that he gets up and goes inside his house. When he comes back, he's holding an armful of vintage suits. Frederick's son, Kaditoza, who was the chubby little baby Frederick was holding in that snapshot, has been sitting with us the whole time. He starts going through his father's suits. That's the color red, red. Red? Red.
就在我们谈话的这一点上，他起身走进屋子。当他回来时，他抱着一大堆复古西装。弗雷德里克的儿子卡迪托扎，就是弗雷德里克在快照中抱着那个胖乎乎的小婴儿，一直和我们坐在一起。他开始翻看他父亲的西装。“那是红色，红色。红色？红色。”
That's the color salmon. One is deep red, kind of bordeaux. There's a dark salmon pink one, a beige one. These suits date back to the 50s. Back then, Frederick filled his wardrobe with them. He bought them secondhand from shops created specifically for so-called évolués like him. Frederick loved those suits. He still does. But they were also in some ways stifling.
“那是鲑鱼色。”一件是深红色，有点像波尔多红。还有一件深鲑鱼粉色，一件米色。这些西装可以追溯到50年代。那时，弗雷德里克用它们填满了他的衣柜。他从专门为像他这样的所谓“进化者”开设的商店里二手买下它们。弗雷德里克很喜欢那些西装。他现在依然喜欢。但在某种程度上，它们也令人窒息。
This elaborate European cosplay that many Congolese had to do just to be treated like human beings. So how do we get from that to the irreverence and joy and freedom of the Sapoors? I was led to the answer while sitting in notoriously awful Kinshasa traffic. One afternoon, I was trying to get to an interview when my taxi lurched to a stop yet again in front of an old shipping container. It had been converted into a shoe store. There was a sign outside featuring a life-sized photo of a middle-aged man in aviators, dressed head to toe in black leather.
这种复杂的欧洲角色扮演，许多刚果人仅仅为了被当作人对待而不得不做。那么我们是如何从那种状态过渡到“萨普尔”的不敬、快乐和自由的呢？我在金沙萨臭名昭著的糟糕交通中找到了答案。一天下午，我正试图去参加一个采访，这时我的出租车又一次停在一个旧集装箱前。它被改造成了一家鞋店。外面有一个招牌，上面有一张戴着飞行员墨镜、从头到脚穿着黑色皮衣的中年男子的真人大小照片。
It read, Papa Grief, Supreme Magistrate and Sapore of the State. When I spoke with the Supreme Magistrate, I explained that I was trying to figure out exactly how suits, of all things, became such a vital form of self-expression in the DRC. Papa Grief didn't mention any tailors or designers. Instead, he pointed to something else as the origin of La Sappe, as the Sappours movement is known. La Sappe in our country was killed by music.. The sap comes from music. The sap in this country was surrounded by music. The sap came from this music. And then he said, let me show you. So the next night, I followed Papa Grief through a hole in a chain link fence into a concrete
上面写着：“格里夫爸爸，最高法官和国家萨普尔”。当我与这位最高法官交谈时，我解释说我正试图弄清楚西装究竟是如何成为刚果民主共和国如此重要的自我表达形式的。格里夫爸爸没有提到任何裁缝或设计师。相反，他指出了“萨普尔”运动（La Sappe）起源的另一个东西。“萨普尔”在我国是被音乐杀死的……“萨普尔”来自音乐。这个国家的“萨普尔”被音乐包围着。“萨普尔”来自这种音乐。然后他说：“让我给你展示一下。”所以第二天晚上，我跟着格里夫爸爸穿过铁丝网围栏上的一个洞，进入了一个混凝土
courtyard. About a dozen guys were lounging with their instruments on overturned plastic drink crates. As we walked in, Papa Grief's band started to play. This is Congolese Roomba. Its roots date back to the 1940s, when Belgian officials were sniff testing Evo Luais at the doors of their office jobs. Like the Evo Luais, the musicians of that era also dressed in suits and ties. But unlike the Evo Luais, their fashion frame of reference wasn't white Belgians. Instead, Congolese artists took their fashion cues from Black American jazz musicians who had been dispatched to Leopoldville to play for U.S. troops during World War II.
庭院。大约十几个人正带着他们的乐器在翻倒的塑料饮料箱上休息。当我们走进去时，格里夫爸爸的乐队开始演奏。这是刚果伦巴。它的根源可以追溯到20世纪40年代，当时比利时官员在办公室门口对“进化者”进行嗅觉测试。像“进化者”一样，那个时代的音乐家也穿着西装打领带。但与“进化者”不同的是，他们的时尚参考框架不是白人比利时人。相反，刚果艺术家从二战期间被派往利奥波德维尔为美军演奏的美国黑人爵士音乐家那里获取时尚灵感。
Locals also went to those shows and were awestruck dressed in suits and bow ties. Didier Mamungi is a Congolese writer, historian, and politician. He says that Congolese civilians used to go see these military bands in concert, and they loved how the Black American groups wore their Western-style suits. Black like the Congolese, but dressed like the Europeans. Dressed better than the Europeans. Better in what sense? In the sense of style. What struck local artists, Didier says, was that the jazz men were Black like the Congolese,
当地人也去看了那些演出，并对穿着西装打领结的他们感到敬畏。迪迪埃·马蒙吉是一位刚果作家、历史学家和政治家。他说，刚果平民过去常去看这些军乐队的音乐会，他们喜欢这些美国黑人团体穿着西式西装的样子。“像刚果人一样黑，但穿着像欧洲人。穿得比欧洲人还好。”“在什么意义上更好？”“在风格的意义上。”迪迪埃说，让当地艺术家感到震惊的是，爵士乐手像刚果人一样是黑人，
but they dressed like Europeans. In fact, he says, they dressed better than Europeans. I asked him, better in what sense? He said, in the sense of style. Although jazz music never really took off in the Congo, jazz fashion definitely did. Congolese musicians quickly began to imitate the way that Black American artists dressed. Roomba fashion looked like it was straight out of Harlem, matching pinstripe suits, glossy loafers, colorful pocket squares.
但他们穿着像欧洲人。事实上，他说，他们穿得比欧洲人还好。我问他，在什么意义上更好？他说，在风格的意义上。虽然爵士乐在刚果从未真正流行起来，但爵士时尚确实流行起来了。刚果音乐家很快开始模仿美国黑人艺术家的穿着方式。伦巴时尚看起来就像直接从哈莱姆区走出来的一样：配套的细条纹西装、光亮的乐福鞋、色彩鲜艳的口袋方巾。
The ingredients of these outfits were similar to what the Évouloués wore, but with flashier colors and bigger accessories. For Congo's department stores, this was awesome news. It meant the suit and tie was now verifiably cool. Store owners started hiring musicians as brand ambassadors who would wear their suits to concerts and bars, and even sometimes sing about them to drum up business. And that's how Congolese begin to equate music with dressing up.
这些服装的成分与“进化者”穿的相似，但颜色更鲜艳，配饰更大。对于刚果的百货公司来说，这是一个好消息。这意味着西装和领带现在确实很酷。店主开始聘请音乐家作为品牌大使，他们会在音乐会和酒吧里穿上西装，有时甚至会唱关于西装的歌来招揽生意。这就是刚果人开始将音乐与盛装打扮联系起来的方式。
The musicians themselves make clothes a central element of the music. Over the next couple of decades, the music really took off as Congolese artists started touring the world. By the 1970s, Roomba filled clubs from Kinshasa to Paris. Papa Grief grew up in this era. The musicians understood that they were in front of the world now, so they really wanted to look good. The patron saint of this music was a flamboyant singer with a high, haunting voice, who went by the stage name Papa Wemba. As Papa Wemba toured the globe, he'd collect luxurious clothes by European and Japanese
音乐家们自己使服装成为音乐的核心元素。在接下来的几十年里，随着刚果艺术家开始在世界各地巡回演出，这种音乐真正流行起来。到了20世纪70年代，伦巴音乐从金沙萨传到了巴黎的俱乐部。格里夫爸爸就是在那个时代长大的。音乐家们明白他们现在站在世界面前，所以他们真的想看起来很棒。这种音乐的守护神是一位有着高亢、令人难忘嗓音的浮夸歌手，他的艺名叫帕帕·温巴。随着帕帕·温巴在全球巡演，他会收集欧洲和日本设计师的奢华服装，
designers, adding new flamboyance to the more classic suit-and-tie look of Roomba artists. He strutted on stage in checkered safari suits with pith helmets and neon yellow bell bottoms with psychedelic print shirts. He was partial to denim, crushed velvet, and floor-length fur coats, which he wore even in the sticky tropical heat. And he loved, loved a fine tailored suit. Here's Papa Wemba explaining in a 2004 documentary why he gravitated to such
为伦巴艺术家的经典西装领带造型增添了新的浮夸感。他在舞台上穿着带有木髓头盔的格子狩猎装，穿着带有迷幻印花衬衫的霓虹黄喇叭裤。他偏爱牛仔布、碎天鹅绒和长及地面的皮草大衣，即使在粘稠的热带高温下他也穿着。而且他喜欢，非常喜欢精致的定制西装。这是帕帕·温巴在2004年的一部纪录片中解释他为什么在职业生涯早期就被这种
extravagant clothes early in his career. I wanted it to be different because all the singers were doing the same thing. So I said to myself, I must find a gimmick, you know? Turn everybody on. You've got to turn the young people on. Fans were already used to seeing Congolese musicians as style icons. But at a talk he gave in 2015, Papa Wimba described how he and other Roomba artists turned their shows into all-out fashion contests.
奢华服装所吸引的原因。“我想与众不同，因为所有的歌手都在做同样的事情。所以我对自己说，我必须找到一个噱头，你知道吗？让每个人都兴奋起来。你必须让年轻人兴奋起来。”粉丝们已经习惯了看到刚果音乐家作为时尚偶像。但在2015年的一次演讲中，帕帕·温巴描述了他和其他伦巴艺术家是如何将他们的演出变成全面的时尚竞赛的。
In the 1970s, when we started our musical careers, there was a group of young people who came from Breasville to take part in the closing battle in Kinshasa. This is where we should clarify that there are two Congos. One is the DRC, with the capital Kinshasa colonized by the Belgians. The other one, just across the Congo River, was colonized by the French. Its capital is Brazzaville. Roomba lovers would take ferries back and forth between the two cities, where there'd
“在20世纪70年代，当我们开始我们的音乐生涯时，有一群来自布拉柴维尔的年轻人来到金沙萨参加闭幕战。”在这里我们应该澄清一下，有两个刚果。一个是刚果民主共和国，首都是金沙萨，被比利时人殖民。另一个，就在刚果河对岸，被法国人殖民。它的首都是布拉柴维尔。伦巴爱好者会乘坐渡轮往返于这两个城市之间，那里会有
be fashion showdowns wherever Papua Wemba and other artists were performing. Well-dressed fans faced off, strutting and posing, showing off designer clothes, as crowds whistled and shouted for the best dressed. Those outfits often came from the overflowing closets of the musicians themselves. Wemba artists collected high-end fashion while on tour, and they'd often sell those pieces used to fans who scrimped and saved for months to buy them. Or fans would get other Congolese traveling abroad to bring designer European clothes back home to Kinshasa and Brazzaville.
时尚对决，无论帕帕·温巴和其他艺术家在哪里表演。衣着考究的粉丝们面对面，昂首阔步，摆出姿势，炫耀着名牌服装，人群为穿着最好的人吹口哨和欢呼。那些服装通常来自音乐家自己堆满衣服的衣柜。温巴的艺术家们在巡演时收集高端时尚，他们经常把那些旧衣服卖给那些攒了几个月钱才买得起的粉丝。或者粉丝们会让其他出国旅行的刚果人把欧洲名牌服装带回金沙萨和布拉柴维尔。
It's not clear exactly who decided this cult of luxury fashion needed a name, but by the mid-1970s, its acolytes were calling themselves SAPPORS, a play on la sap, a French slang word for clothing. The SAPPORS added a Congolese flourish to the term by making S-A-P-E, an acronym that means the society of ambiance makers and elegant persons. and elegant persons. La Sap was about dressing up to look good, to look elegant. It was also about the ambiance, the glow that you the Sappor in your fine, beautiful formal wear brought into the world. In one of Papa Wemba's songs, Aisa Nzawazoa, he has a line that's become like a creed to
目前还不清楚究竟是谁决定这种奢侈时尚崇拜需要一个名字，但到了20世纪70年代中期，它的追随者们开始自称为“萨普尔”（SAPEURS），这是对“la sape”的戏称，这是一个法语俚语，意为服装。萨普尔人通过将S-A-P-E作为一个缩写词，为这个词增添了刚果特色，意思是“氛围营造者和优雅人士协会”。“La Sappe”是关于盛装打扮以看起来好看、看起来优雅。它也关于氛围，你这位萨普尔人在你精致、美丽的正式服装中带给世界的光芒。在帕帕·温巴的一首歌《Aisa Nzawazoa》中，他有一句歌词已经成为萨普尔人的信条。
the Sappores. It goes like this, what was he like? Well dressed, well shaved, or sapology. Unlike Papa Wemba, most Congolese rumba fans couldn't really afford a closet full of silk shirts and designer suits. But the Sapoors believed that if you could find a way to dress expensively, the world would treat you like an expensive person, whether you were a famous rumba musician or a construction worker.
它是这样的：“他看起来怎么样？衣着考究，剃须干净，这就是萨普尔学。”与帕帕·温巴不同，大多数刚果伦巴粉丝其实买不起一柜子的丝绸衬衫和名牌西装。但萨普尔人相信，如果你能找到一种方法穿得昂贵，世界就会把你当作一个昂贵的人来对待，无论你是著名的伦巴音乐家还是建筑工人。
Here's Papa Grief again. Clothing changes a person. We recognize students by their uniforms. We recognize professional athletes by the jersey they wear. We know lawyers by their robes and doctors by their coats. You know a soldier when you see them because of their uniforms too. This is how you know who someone is. When you see a madman, you will understand that the mad is how you know who someone is. To the Sappores, fine formal wear announced to the world that you were the kind of person who deserved luxury. In the grand scheme, suits are a small thing.
这是格里夫爸爸再次发言。“服装改变一个人。我们通过制服认出学生。我们通过他们穿的球衣认出职业运动员。我们通过长袍认出律师，通过白大褂认出医生。当你看到士兵时，你也因为他们的制服而认出他们。这就是你如何知道某人是谁。当你看到一个疯子，你会明白那个疯子……这就是你如何知道某人是谁。”对于萨普尔人来说，精致的正式服装向世界宣告你是一个值得拥有奢侈品的人。从宏观上看，西装是一件小事。
But Lesap formed as proof that anyone could be a person who mattered, just by looking the part. For a lot of young Congolese, that idea was extraordinary. So extraordinary that it didn't matter that you were going to have to totally break the bank to make it happen. That's how Yinda Gabi felt. When she was 20 years old, in the early 1980s, she went to a Papua Wemba concert in Kinshasa. She watched as he walked on stage wearing a floor-length black Versace coat. And she just couldn't stop looking at it.
但“La Sappe”的形成证明了任何人都可以成为一个重要的人，仅仅通过看起来像那样。对于许多年轻的刚果人来说，这个想法是非凡的。如此非凡，以至于你必须倾家荡产才能实现它也无所谓。这就是因达·加比的感觉。20世纪80年代初，她20岁时，去金沙萨看了一场帕帕·温巴的音乐会。她看着他穿着一件长及地面的黑色范思哲大衣走上舞台。她简直无法移开视线。
She says when she saw that jacket, it was love at first sight, like a thunderbolt going through her. Yenda became a woman obsessed. Since Papa Wemba was a distant friend of the family, she approached him and asked if he'd sell her the jacket. He said yes, for $100. That was a lot of money. She was a young mother selling meat at a tiny market stall, making at most a couple dollars a day.
她说当她看到那件夹克时，那是一见钟情，就像一道闪电击中了她。因达成了一个痴迷的女人。由于帕帕·温巴是她家的一位远房朋友，她走近他，问他是否愿意把那件夹克卖给她。他说愿意，100美元。那是一大笔钱。她是一位年轻的母亲，在一个小市场摊位上卖肉，每天最多赚几美元。
But she immediately forked over her entire savings. Yinda never regretted her very expensive purchase. When she put on that jacket, people just looked at her differently. They spoke to her more respectfully. She felt tougher and braver. She became a Sappor. It transformed my life. It made me known. She began spending more and more money on clothes and swapping outfits with other Sappors. She even gave herself a new name.
但她立刻交出了她所有的积蓄。因达从未后悔过她那次非常昂贵的购买。当她穿上那件夹克时，人们看她的眼神都不一样了。他们对她说话更尊重了。她感到更坚强、更勇敢。她成了一名萨普尔人。“它改变了我的生活。它让我出名了。”她开始花越来越多的钱买衣服，并与其他萨普尔人交换服装。她甚至给自己起了一个新名字。
I'm Yinda Gabi, but people know me as Mama Mineur. Mama Mineur basically means youthful mother. Women Sopors are also known as Sapoos. When she joined the movement in the 80s, there weren't many. She's still one of the few. Most of her clothes are what we think of as menswear. But she says in La Sappe, it doesn't work like that. Because the women are not fit.
“我是因达·加比，但人们叫我‘米尼尔妈妈’。”米尼尔妈妈基本上意味着“年轻的母亲”。女性萨普尔人也被称为“萨普斯”（Sapeuses）。当她在80年代加入这个运动时，并没有多少女性。她仍然是少数几个之一。她的大部分衣服都是我们认为的男装。但她说在“La Sappe”中，情况并非如此。“因为女性不适合。”
They are not fit. They are not fit. They are not fit. A Sapoor is a kind of rebel. In la sappe, there's no difference between men's and women's clothes. There was a freedom for women and a freedom for men also. If a man wants to wear a skirt, he can wear a skirt. By the 1980s, the Sappores had totally rebranded European formal wear. The Belgians had required Africans to wear suits to prove their European-ness.
“她们不适合。她们不适合。她们不适合。”萨普尔人是一种叛逆者。在“La Sappe”中，男装和女装没有区别。女性有一种自由，男性也有自由。如果一个男人想穿裙子，他可以穿裙子。到了20世纪80年代，“萨普尔”已经完全重塑了欧洲正装。比利时人曾要求非洲人穿西装以证明他们的欧洲性。
American jazz artists, at least in the eyes of the Congolese, had worn suits to affirm their dignity. Sappores were defining suits and fine fashion again. They weren't just cool, they were very Congolese. Coming up, the infamous dictator who tried to kill the Sappors vibes. That's after the break, but first here's Roman with some ads. Not everyone loved Congolese people strutting around like the Sappors in bright and flamboyant European formal wear.
美国爵士艺术家，至少在刚果人眼中，穿西装是为了维护他们的尊严。萨普尔人再次定义了西装和高级时尚。它们不仅很酷，而且非常刚果。接下来，试图扼杀萨普尔氛围的臭名昭著的独裁者。休息后回来，但首先是罗曼带来的广告。并不是每个人都喜欢刚果人像萨普尔人那样穿着鲜艳、浮夸的欧洲正装到处走动。
One person who hated the idea was the president, Mobutu Sese Seko. If that name sounds familiar, it's because Mobutu is notorious for his wild exploitation of the DRC. He conspired with the CIA to have the Congo's first prime minister, Patrice Lumumba, assassinated. And when Mobutu took over in the mid-1960s, he quickly became a kleptocratic dictator of note. He enjoyed riding his yacht down the Congo and chartering Concorde jets for weekend trips to his personal castle in Spain.
一个讨厌这个想法的人是总统蒙博托·塞塞·塞科。如果这个名字听起来很熟悉，那是因为蒙博托因其对刚果民主共和国的疯狂剥削而臭名昭著。他与中央情报局勾结，暗杀了刚果第一任总理帕特里斯·卢蒙巴。当蒙博托在20世纪60年代中期接管政权时，他很快成为了一名著名的盗贼统治独裁者。他喜欢乘游艇沿刚果河航行，并包租协和式飞机去他在西班牙的私人城堡度周末。
Stuff like that. Matthew 6.1 Mobutu despised the way that Belgian colonists had tried to bleach the Congolese of their own cultures. Here he is explaining why he was fed up with Europe's influence in the Congo. To exploit the black men, the colonizer wiped out African traditions, languages, and cultures. In short, totally negating the black man so that he thinks, speaks, eats, dresses, laughs, and breathes like a white man. As president, Mobutu took a hard turn towards nationalism.
诸如此类的事情。马太福音6.1。蒙博托鄙视比利时殖民者试图抹去刚果人自身文化的方式。这是他解释为什么他厌倦了欧洲在刚果的影响。“为了剥削黑人，殖民者抹杀了非洲的传统、语言和文化。简而言之，完全否定了黑人，使他像白人一样思考、说话、吃饭、穿衣、欢笑和呼吸。”作为总统，蒙博托在民族主义方面进行了急转弯。
He changed the country's name to Zaire, a word derived from an indigenous term for the Congo River. And he scrapped colonial city names like Leopoldville and Stanleyville. He also banned Western names like Marie and Pierre. For him, the point was to rid Zaire of the symbols of Belgian colonialism. Mobutu called this new policy, Authenticite. He had thought of it as a movement of complete decolonization of Congolese spirits. Congolese scholar Didier Mamungi says Mbutu thought of Authenticite as a movement to completely decolonize the Congolese spirit. For Mbutu, it was crucial that all Zaireans show unwavering faith in his new program. Authenticity!
他将国名改为扎伊尔，这个词源于刚果河的一个土著词。他废除了像利奥波德维尔和斯坦利维尔这样的殖民城市名称。他还禁止了像玛丽和皮埃尔这样的西方名字。对他来说，重点是清除扎伊尔的比利时殖民主义符号。蒙博托称这项新政策为“真实性”（Authenticité）。他认为这是一场刚果精神彻底去殖民化的运动。刚果学者迪迪埃·马蒙吉说，蒙博托认为“真实性”是一场彻底去殖民化刚果精神的运动。对于蒙博托来说，所有扎伊尔人表现出对他新计划的坚定信仰至关重要。真实性！
And political philosophy! In a documentary about Mobutu, he's shown sitting on a throne made of carved wood and green velvet. The dictator is watching, pleased, as a room full of people robotically parrot lines, praising authenticity and Zaire. Zaire!
还有政治哲学！在一部关于蒙博托的纪录片中，他被展示坐在一个由雕刻木头和绿色天鹅绒制成的宝座上。独裁者看着，很满意，因为满屋子的人像机器人一样鹦鹉学舌，赞美真实性和扎伊尔。扎伊尔！
Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire!
扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！
Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! Zaire! believed, like the Sepors, that how you dressed was directly linked to who you were. But he wanted people to look Zairean.
扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！扎伊尔！相信，像萨普尔人一样，你的穿着与你是谁直接相关。但他希望人们看起来像扎伊尔人。
In his early days as the leader of Zaire, when he was hobnobbing with Western kings and presidents, Mobutu typically wore a classic suit and tie. But in the early 1970s, he did a fashion 180. If you've ever seen a photo of Mobutu, there's a very good chance he's dressed as follows. His trademark leopard-skin cap, big, thick, buddy-holly glasses, a carved wooden walking stick, and something that he'd invented that looks kind of like a cross between a lightweight blazer and a dress shirt buttoned up to the collar. He called this new creation the Abacost. Abacost is short for Aba le Cost costume, which literally means down with the suit.
在他担任扎伊尔领导人的早期，当他与西方国王和总统交际时，蒙博托通常穿经典的西装和领带。但在20世纪70年代初，他进行了一次时尚180度大转弯。如果你见过蒙博托的照片，很有可能他是这样打扮的：他标志性的豹皮帽、大而厚的巴迪·霍利眼镜、雕刻的木制手杖，以及他发明的一种看起来介于轻便西装外套和扣到领口的衬衫之间的东西。他称这个新创造为“阿巴科斯特”（Abacost）。“Abacost”是“Aba le Cost”服装的缩写，字面意思是“打倒西装”。
And it was Mobutu's personal response to the European suit and tie. Well, it was his personal response that he more or less copied directly from China. It had what was then called a Mao color, but to make it a bit different, the color was slightly elongated with the scarf in the place of a tie. And voila, the Abacost. As part of Authenticité, Mobutu had come up with a new national dress code, and he made the Abacost the official office uniform in Zaire.
这是蒙博托对欧洲西装和领带的个人回应。好吧，这是他个人回应，他或多或少直接从中国抄袭了它。它有当时所谓的“毛领”，但为了让它有点不同，领子稍微拉长了，用围巾代替了领带。瞧，阿巴科斯特。作为“真实性”的一部分，蒙博托制定了新的国家着装规范，并使阿巴科斯特成为扎伊尔的官方办公室制服。
And then, to round off his down with the suit messaging, he actually made it against the law for men to wear western suits and ties. But bans are made to be broken, and the dictator's anti-suit laws certainly didn't stop the Sappors from continuing to flaunt their fanciest clothes. And suddenly, dressing like a European dandy took on a whole new political connotation. Now, La Sappe was an act of rebellion against the eccentric dictator. La Sappe, la joie, c'était un mouvement de révolte, de révendication. La Sappe was a joy, and that alone was a revolt against Mobutu.
然后，为了完善他的“打倒西装”信息，他实际上立法禁止男性穿西式西装和领带。但禁令是为了被打破而制定的，独裁者的反西装法律当然没有阻止萨普尔人继续炫耀他们最华丽的衣服。突然之间，像欧洲绅士一样打扮带上了全新的政治内涵。现在，“La Sappe”是对这位古怪独裁者的反叛行为。“La Sappe，la joie，c'était un mouvement de révolte，de révendication。”“La Sappe”是一种快乐，仅此一点就是对蒙博托的反抗。
It was a statement, because he said, you have forbidden us to live our lives like we want, you have forbidden us to speak as we want, but there is a space that a dictator like you cannot control, and that is our bodies. The Sappor's flashy, uber-expensive style was an act of resistance in another way, too. Because here's the thing. By the 1980s, Mobutu Zaire was melting down. As part of Authenticite, he seized foreign-owned businesses and mostly let them rot.
这是一种声明，因为他说，你禁止我们按照我们想要的方式生活，你禁止我们按照我们想要的方式说话，但有一个空间是像你这样的独裁者无法控制的，那就是我们的身体。萨普尔人浮夸、超级昂贵的风格在另一方面也是一种抵抗行为。因为事情是这样的：到了20世纪80年代，蒙博托的扎伊尔正在崩溃。作为“真实性”的一部分，他没收了外资企业，并基本上任由它们腐烂。
Commodities tanked, and the country was plunged into debt. Oh, and Mabutu was stealing crazy amounts of money, something like half the national budget each year. The dictator himself talked about how broke his country was. On Zaire, financially ill, many doctors are suffering. Many doctors are examining a financially sick Zaire. Some want shock treatment, others want radical surgery. As Zaire's economy crumbled, so did its infrastructure.
大宗商品价格暴跌，国家陷入债务。哦，蒙博托每年都在窃取疯狂的资金，大约是国家预算的一半。独裁者本人谈到了他的国家有多穷。“在扎伊尔，经济上生病了，许多医生正在受苦。许多医生正在检查一个经济上生病的扎伊尔。有些人想要休克疗法，有些人想要彻底的手术。”随着扎伊尔经济的崩溃，其基础设施也随之崩溃。
And in the midst of those dark days, Sappors could be seen strutting down Kinshasa streets, littered with potholes and gurgling with raw sewage in their designer trench coats and thousand dollar crocodile loafers. The Sappors weren't just pushing back against Mobutu's dress code. They seemed to be an open rebellion against their country's bleak reality. There was so little money to be had, and here they were choosing to blow it on like pocket watches and fedoras. As if to say, we refuse to let these difficult circumstances ruin our ambiance or scuff our fine leather boots.
在那些黑暗的日子里，萨普尔人可以看到在金沙萨的街道上昂首阔步，街道上满是坑洼，污水横流，他们穿着名牌风衣和价值千美元的鳄鱼皮乐福鞋。萨普尔人不仅在反抗蒙博托的着装规范。他们似乎是在公开反抗他们国家阴郁的现实。几乎没有钱可赚，而他们却选择把钱花在怀表和软呢帽上。仿佛在说，我们拒绝让这些困难的环境破坏我们的氛围或磨损我们的高级皮靴。
In a larger grand scheme of the social realities of what's happening in the Congo, it's frivolous, right? This is a frivolous activity. This is author Chantrell Lewis again. But for me, anytime someone can use resources to create the type of reality that they want to live, and even if that is to imagine this luxury lifestyle, I believe that's an act of power and agency and resistance. Eventually, Zaire's economic situation forced many to leave the country.
“在刚果正在发生的社会现实的宏观计划中，这是轻浮的，对吧？这是一种轻浮的活动。”这是作者尚特雷尔·刘易斯再次发言。“但对我来说，任何时候有人能够利用资源来创造他们想要生活的现实，即使那是为了想象这种奢侈的生活方式，我相信这是一种力量、自主权和抵抗的行为。”最终，扎伊尔的经济状况迫使许多人离开这个国家。
That migration accelerated in the mid-1990s, after Mabutu was deposed by a rebel army, and then a brutal civil war erupted. As hundreds of thousands of Zairean migrants fanned out across the world, they took the culture of La Salle with them. fanned out across the world, they took the culture of La Sappe with them. Especially to Europe, where Sappoers now had regular access to brands and styles that had been hard to come by at home. The tradition of Sappoer fashion duels found new life in the nightclubs of Paris and Brussels. European filmmakers began capturing Sappoapor culture for a global audience.
这种移民在20世纪90年代中期加速，在蒙博托被叛军推翻，随后爆发了残酷的内战之后。随着成千上万的扎伊尔移民散布到世界各地，他们把“La Sappe”的文化带到了世界各地。特别是欧洲，萨普尔人现在可以经常接触到在国内很难买到的品牌和款式。萨普尔时尚对决的传统在巴黎和布鲁塞尔的夜总会中找到了新的生命。欧洲电影制作人开始为全球观众捕捉萨普尔文化。
In a 2004 documentary, a group of Sapor's are seen standing in a plaza in Belgium, boasting about the brands they're wearing, Comme des Garçons, Versace and Yoji Yamamoto. One of the Sapor's points at the camera and declares in Lingala,
在2004年的一部纪录片中，一群萨普尔人被看到站在比利时的一个广场上，吹嘘他们穿的品牌：Comme des Garçons、范思哲和山本耀司。其中一名萨普尔人指着镜头，用林加拉语宣布，
this is the story of wicked fashion. By the early 2000s, Sappors were getting attention around the world. At the same time, journalists and photographers started traveling to Africa to report on Sappor culture in Kinshasa and Brazzaville. That's one of the phenomena that made the Sapir culture so prominent was that it occurred during the time when social media began to be on the rise. So now the Sapir were the subjects
“这是邪恶时尚的故事。”到了21世纪初，萨普尔人受到了全世界的关注。与此同时，记者和摄影师开始前往非洲报道金沙萨和布拉柴维尔的萨普尔文化。“使萨普尔文化如此突出的现象之一是，它发生在社交媒体开始兴起的时候。所以现在萨普尔人成为了日常摄影师的主题，这向我们所有人打开了他们的世界。”去年，刚果举办了法语国家运动会，这是一种法语世界的奥运会。金沙萨的开幕式是传统刚果舞蹈、歌曲和木偶戏的混合体。然后，在演出中间，体育场突然完全变黑了。一排黄色出租车从黑暗中出现，车灯闪烁。然后车门猛地打开。一群穿着细条纹西装、戴着一英尺高礼帽和虹彩金色西装外套的人开始
of everyday photographers, which then opened up their world to all of us. Last year, Congo hosted the Francophone Games, a kind of Olympics for the French-speaking world. The opening ceremony in Kinshasa was a medley of traditional Congolese dance, song and puppetry. And then in the middle of the show, the stadium suddenly went completely black. A row of yellow taxis appeared out of the darkness, headlights blazing. Then the car doors flung open. A bunch of people in pinstripe suits and foot-tall top hats and iridescent gold blazers started
涌出。“萨普尔人，他们显然是标志性人物。他们从出租车里出来。”在如此大的舞台上看到萨普尔人，我很清楚他们已经以最好的方式进入了主流。这种大胆、浮夸的奢侈时尚崇拜曾经是反主流文化。但当我在金沙萨时，
pouring out. And the sappers, who are obviously the emblematic characters. Who come out of the taxi. Seeing the sappers on such a big stage, it was clear to me that they had gone mainstream, in the best possible way. This bold, extravagant cult of luxury fashion used to be counterculture. But when I was in Kinshasa,
许多刚果人告诉我，现在，“La Sappe，c'est notre patrimoine national。”“La Sappe”是我们的国家遗产。["Petite Salle"] 《99% Invisible》本周由瑞安·莱诺拉·布朗报道，由我克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作和编辑。混音和声音设计由马丁·冈萨雷斯负责，音乐由斯旺·里尔和凯克·奥唐奈创作，
many Congolese told me that now, La Sappe, c'est notre patrimoine national. La Sappe is our national heritage. ["Petite Salle"] 99% Invisible was reported this week by Ryan Lenora Brown and produced and edited by me, Christopher Johnson. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and Cake O'Donnell,
事实核查由格雷厄姆·海耶沙负责。本周特别感谢克里斯汀·拉西斯特、伊芙·桑布、莱昂·桑布、卡迪托萨以及我们在金沙萨的联络人乔普拉·卡班比。还要感谢恩库穆·卡塔莱、艾米莉亚·蒙古·马汉迪的配音以及姆万比拉刚果舞蹈团。罗曼·马尔斯是我们的最高法官和氛围营造者。
fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks this week to Kristen Lassiste, Eve Sambu, Leon Sambu, Kaditosa and our fixer and kinshasa, Chopra Kabambi. Also thanks to Nkumu Katalai, Emilia Mungu Mahandi for the voiceovers and the Mfwambila Congo Dance Company. Roman Mars is our supreme magistrate and ambiance maker.
凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·卡尔斯特是我们的数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。我们团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·利、拉莎·马登、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、莎拉·贝克和尼娜·波托克。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kallstedt is our digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of our incredible team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Lasha Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Sarah Bake, and Nina Potok. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，本集是在我们位于美丽、混乱的曼哈顿中城的演播室和办公室制作的。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们新的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，你可以去收听《99PI》每一集过去的节目，网址是99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family and this episode was produced in our studios and offices in beautiful, chaotic, midtown Manhattan. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that and you can go off listening to every single solitary past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，本期节目是在我们位于美丽而混乱的曼哈顿中城的演播室和办公室制作的。您可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们新的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，您可以前往99PI.org收听99PI每一期过往的节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。